éduqué en face
on est ronde a fait un mea culpa soir
temps doux
oh oui oh
oh mec
[Musique]
oh mais que la tête que je lui ai mis au
la tête
[Musique]
pour l'une des premières fois un jeu
réussi totalement à me faire décrocher
de league of legends et ça fait six ans
que j'y joue c'est fortnight je découvre
fraîchement les battle royale et je
surkiffe de plus en tant que possesseur
de la switch j'aimerais beaucoup voir un
portage de fortes night sur cette
dernière
mais arrivera t'il réellement c'est ce
que nous allons voir tout de suite
or ce night est réellement le jeu du
moment disponible sur pc
ps4 et xbox one il ne manque plus que
nintendo
je suis certain que le jeu arrivera sur
switch j'en suis convaincu mais il n'est
pas prévu sur la console pour le moment
le premier problème étant que la switch
est arrivée nettement après la nouvelle
génération de consoles ps4 et xbox one
il faut qu'elle s'adapte c'est pour ça
que vous avez pu voir de nombreuses
sorties autres que des jeux nintendo
comme minecraft roquettes ligue ou fifa
18 par exemple mais ce qui fait un peu
grincer des dents sur un futur portage
de forte taille sur switch c'est que
c'est un free to play ce qui est
totalement inverse des jeux nintendo
je pense sincèrement que si le jeu
arrive sur switch il sera normalement au
free to play mais connaissant nintendo
le jeu pourrait se vendre une petite
somme donc avoir néanmoins tout serait
bénef pour nintendo fortnight est réputé
pour sa battle royale donc le mode en
ligne est une nintendo prévoit de faire
payer le online de la switch d'ici
septembre
quoi de mieux qu exploiter le mode
online de fortnight pour de nombreux
abonnements on line sur switch ensuite
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'un jeu
comme forte nine tournerait aisément sur
nintendo switch à noter que l'univers et
les graphismes colle encore plus avec
l'univers de nintendo
de plus certains pourraient parler de la
densité de l'amap de fortes night que la
switch aurait du mal à tout exploiter
je ne suis pas trop d'accord avec ça
preuve avec la carte de zelda breath of
the wild
pour continuer il faut noter aussi que
donald mustard l'un des gérants d'epic
games est très intéressé pour un portage
de son jeu sur la nintendo switch
donc si nintendo sont ouverts à ce
dernier il pourrait très bien discuter
de ce portage ce ne serait que du bénef
pour nintendo comme je le disais puis
j'ai envie de dire il n'y a pas de
raison que fortnight ne soit pas sur la
switch nintendo pratiquer énormément
l'individualisme depuis des années
mais grâce à la switch ces derniers se
sont ouverts et énormément de
partenariat sont nés notamment avec
ubisoft pour mario plus lapins crétins
kingdom batol beaucoup de jeux indé
comme pacman céleste ya même dark souls
sur la switch donc pourquoi pas un
battle royale permettrait de toucher
encore un nouveau public et le portage
de fortes night sur switch est très
demandé par les fans je vous le dis
sincèrement je pense que fortnight
arrivera sur switch mais quand et bien
vers fin 2018 je dirais vers septembre
pourquoi car le service online payant de
nintendo arrive vers fin 2018 sans ça
elle ne tirerait pas énormément de
bénéfices contrairement à la playstation
qu'à tous les xbox one dont le service
online est payant déjà depuis un moment
néanmoins si un portage doit arriver
nintendo doit faire attention à l'effet
de mode
est-ce que first night sera encore
autant jouer dans quelques mois
est ce que les fans seront encore au
taquet c'est à vous de le décider et je
peux vous assurer que si je fonctionne
autant encore lors de cette période le
jeu arrivera sur la switch donc tout
repose sur vous voilà je voulais vous
exprimer mon avis là dessus car il est
vrai que très peu d'infos ont été
communiqués à ce jeu j'espère que cette
petite vidéo vous aura plu
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner activer la
petite cloche et surtout me suivre sur
twitter c'est très important
cet argot rock et que le lion's soit
avec vous
[Musique]